when was Zone have decided for the first
time yes the girls can wear whatever
color they want underneath their white
skirts and I spoke to Heather watts and
the British player who's very outspoken
about her periods addressing this this
taboo subject in women's sport which
really it shouldn't be because it
happens to all women you know half of
the half of the planet go through this
so she's been talking about what it
means to her that they've changed this
Rule and she is very relieved
when I heard this I was really happy
because I remember last year I
um again like I said I speak openly some
people might cringe at this but I went
on the pill to stop myself bleeding
because I knew we had to wear white
undershots and I didn't want to face any
embarrassment with that I didn't want to
have to you know we're running around
sweating doing the splits on the court
so
um this year I knew my period was going
to be during Wimbledon again so I'm very
happy that I won't have to do the same
thing as last year
so very very honest there from her and
also very honest from the American
player Coco Goff she's just 19 but she's
got a great head on her shoulders the
number seven seed who's shot to fame
here at Wimbledon as a 16 year old
beating Venus Williams her Idol over
there on court number one she's grown up
a lot since then she has also been
talking about this subject and also very
happy about the rule change
I was on my period last year during
Wimbledon and it was very stressful I
mean you know there's always you know
you have the you know the period
underwear and stuff to help you but you
know it's still in the back of your mind
and sometimes like I mean I know you're
when you go to the bathroom you're
supposed to use the bathroom but you
know sometimes I will go to the bathroom
just to check um to make sure that
nothing was showing so I think it's
going to relieve a lot of stress for me
and other girls in the locker room for
sure